hello and welcome back to another video
today we're going to be talking about
batum ryota an unemployed 22 year old is
an elite japanese player of batum an mmo
which sold almost 3 million copies
worldwide with his team ranked as 10th
in the whole world in the present an
amnesiac ryota awakens in a parachute
harness on a tropical island only
equipped with his bag containing a few
necessities a pouch full of countdown
bomb-like weapons called timer bims and
a strange bead-like chip embedded on his
left hand at night on the beach he's
pursued by someone who attacks him with
cracker bims failing to reason with him
ryota is forced to evade behind the
bushes realizing that he's forced to
play batoon for real when his opponent
corners him near a cliff ryota then sets
a trap by leaving a time of him on the
cliff and jumping into the ocean which
kills his assailant later while we're in
the jungle near a river he sees a girl
her name is himiko she just escaped from
a man called mitsuo who wanted to rape
her and from a killer named masashi
because of this she believes that
everyone on the island is her enemy
ryota attempts to talk with himiko about
her case full of food but she runs away
in the bushes when riota tries to locate
her he instead stumbles upon a man named
kiyoshi he explains that he was also
approached by two men after which he
woke up on a cargo plane with a small
crowd of people who were all informed by
a cheerful man on screen about their
participation in a death game on the
tropical island after they all learned
that the objective of completing the
game is to collect ic chips from eight
other participants after they're killed
many of them were infuriated but masked
men aboard the plane arm would stun guns
subdued them ryotar was the most
outspoken of the group and seemed to
know the man in charge but he was
shocked in the head with a stun gun
which explained his lost memories the
plane reached the island and the
participants were thrown out with
parachutes ryotar realizes that terranis
japan the group who we create in batum
was most likely responsible for this as
ryota and kiyoshi decide to team up to
improve their odds they notice another
plane dropping food supplies onto the
island when ryotar races after a food
supply a woman reaches it first only for
her to be killed by a trap set by a man
who then just takes it and leaves
riyotta and gyoshi then contemplate on
whether they should pursue another
parachute but they eventually decide to
do so since they wouldn't be able to
defend themselves if their strength was
low upon reaching the parachute they
discover a small boy covered in blood
who appears to have killed another man
for the food supply in the past a 14
year old sadistic necrophiliac named
kosuke was arrested for murdering three
women back in the present a lawyer named
suici discovers goscayne near the shore
skewering frogs for fun soichi tries to
explain that it's wrong to kill living
things out of amusement but gosu rejects
the explanation after a food supply
drops nearby the two investigate it with
gorsuch's abusive father he's forcing
his son to use an implosion bim to
retrieve the food supply from a tree
decides to take the case for himself
going on about survival of the fittest
ghostgate tired of the abuse activates
an implosion bim on his father and kills
him feeling a rush of euphoria soichi
runs away frightened saying kosuki is
akin to a monster at this point kosuke
is discovered by ryota and gyoshi who
retreat after failing to reason with him
as ghost gay chases after them with the
intent to kill ryotar decides to fight
in order to protect kyoshi ryota and
gosuke soon recognize each other as
batoon players and engage after kosuke
taunton attacks him ryota hits his head
against a rock which causes a
personality shift where he perceives
reality as being the game world ryotar
defeats gorsuch by hiding his movements
with advanced sonar cancelling although
ryotar can't bring himself to kill the
kid he binds him to a tree taking his
food supply and his bims when our emcee
leaves gonski is thrilled to learn ryota
is actually the top ranked japanese
player of batum
while riota and kyoshi are eating near
the river the course of mitsuho without
pants washes down stream leaving ryota
and kiyoshi to speculate ryota
suspecting that an enemy may be lurking
upstream goes to investigate and
discovers himiko waiting atop a cliff
she draws him out into the open by
throwing a blazing gas bim into the
forest although he attempts to reason
with her she attacks him with a cracker
bim prompting him to charge at her she
uses her stun gun to defend herself but
ryotar causes her to stun herself and
land on top of him he's tempted to grope
her while she's unconscious but he
decides not to as she was previously
assaulted by mitsuo himiko awakens in
riyadh's arms and upon the fear of being
violated again activates a timer beam
hidden in her pocket but ryota
deactivates it back at the campsite she
explains to ryota and kiyoshi that
everyone on the island had been chosen
by someone they knew that wanted to make
them disappear
himiko knows that her friend chose her
for being betrayed kiyoshi deduces that
a real estate customer might have chosen
him due to an argument and ryotar
realizes that his own mother had chosen
him for defying her suddenly the group
is attacked by a pack of komodo dragons
after himiko passes out kiyoshi carries
her to the other side of the river
leaving ryotar to handle the komodo
dragons ryota realizes that others bims
are rendered useless if their owner is
alive after a komodo dragon bites
kyoshi's leg ryotar manages to activate
one of his cracker bims to scare it off
while ryotar carries himiko on his back
kyoshi carries all the food supplies and
bims suddenly a komodo dragon appears
and causes the two to get separated
riyada having failed to find kyoshi with
his sonar thinks he's betrayed them
leaving them without weapons or food but
when they're attacked by a komodo dragon
kiyoshi undoubtably returns and kills it
using a homing bim confirming that their
sonars cancelled out when they were
searching for each other they're
followed by more komodo dragons to an
abandoned communications tower near the
sea kiyoshi tries to hold off the komodo
dragon using homing bims but not too
much effect this prompts ryotar to use
one of himiko's blazing gas beams by
using her finger to activate the switch
to drive the komodo dragons away later
when himiko regains consciousness she
still feels uncomfortable after ryota
touches her shoulder after kiyoshi's leg
becomes infected ryota asks himiko to
hold down kiyoshi to disinfect it back
in the mainland it's revealed that
terraness japan is monitoring the events
on the island especially with a special
interest in riota as ryotar notices the
variety of food supplies and bims that
hemiko possesses he concludes that she
had murdered many other participants
putting her under suspicion soon they're
suddenly discovered by another
participant sona and ryotar decides to
be a decoy to draw the assailant away
from his friends in the forest ryota is
attacked by the assailant who's revealed
to be masashi in the past ryota and
himiko got married in the batoon world
but himiko didn't want to meet him in
the real world just yet riota realizing
that masashi and soichi are working
together is overpowered and has his bims
confiscated although masashi allows
ryota to escape after shocking soichi
with a stun gun this was his plan to
track ryotar back to the abandoned
communications tower ryota tries to
reason with masashi saying that the
entire scenario was set up by terranis
japan to iron out bugs in batum as there
may be a loophole allowing everyone to
survive however masashi is slicing
kyoshi's fingers off and pushing ryota
off the cliff into the trees before he
leaves ryotar returns unharmed and finds
himiko's phone realizing she may be the
same himacha whom he knew in the game
judging from her cosplay wallpaper at
another abandoned building masashi and
soichi tie himiko down on a bed and
proceed to torture her a little bit
ryota leaving kyoshi behind uses his
sonar to signal and locate himiko
prompting masashi and soichi to search
for him after untying her ryotar
questions if she's the himiko he once
played with in batum but she denies this
the two are attacked by suici who is
consequently killed by his own cracker
bim the ryota previously disabled
masashi then holds himiko hostage
challenging ryota to a fistfight instead
ryota rushes for masashi's knife only to
be beaten to the ground himiko then
jumps on masashi and activates a blazing
gas bim on him ryota and himiko tried to
escape by going through an opening in
the ceiling but masashi grabs himacho's
leg to drag her back down however ryotar
reactivates suici's timer bim which soon
detonates and kills masashi riota and
himiko take refuge in yet another
abandoned building at night ryonta
explains that he views the game world
more as reality especially with his
relationship with the himiko he knew in
bhutum hence his reason for saving her
from masashi himiko silently breaks into
tears not expecting to meet ryota in the
real world and afraid of revealing her
true identity as the himmico in the game
world due to her previous traumatic
experiences himiko wakes up in the
middle of the night and screams upon the
sight of a ghost riyada investigates and
discovers a seemingly crazed woman
living nearby knocking her out when she
attacks him ryota brings him a go with
him to calm down the woman who was a
survivor from a previous iteration of
the batoon death game
shiki was a nurse at an understaffed
hospital working with a doctor named
masahito who blamed her for his medical
malpractice as they were both chosen to
participate in the death game the doctor
blasts off her left arm after obtaining
six icy chips and takes her chip after
betraying her leaving the island for a
helicopter as ryota and himeko say
goodbye to shiki it's revealed that
masahito went back to the island to
treat kiyoshi's wounds ryota and himiko
returned to kiyoshi who has his wounds
treated by masahito who tricks them all
into gaining their trust discreetly
intending to betray them and take their
icy chips later on a new food supply
case arrives on the island urging ryotar
himiko and masahito to rush for it ryota
engages in a fight with a man wearing
sunglasses named nobutaka masahito
catches the food supply case and brings
it towards ryota who runs away from
nobutaka however after a fire occurs
nobutaka grabs the food supply case and
dives off a cliff into the ocean as to
which ryota follows him meanwhile himiko
is attacked by a young female who
constantly taunts her while they're
fighting masahito throws a remote
control bim their way intending to kill
them both however he notices that himiko
is still alive and pretends that he was
trying to save her ryota resurfaces near
a beach and witnesses another player
fought for nobutaka's booby trap he
comes out of hiding and threatens
nobutaka with a cracker bim telling him
to drop all of his equipment nobutaka
obeys which causes riota to get
suspicious as ryota approaches the
equipment nobutaka activates a hidden
remote control bim and seemingly kills
ryota but when he activates his sonar
he's surprised to see ryota's still
alive
nobutaka leaves after he realizes who he
was fighting leaving ryotar to wonder
how he knows his name when ryota himiko
and masahito return to kyoshi ryota
remembers that nobutaka was his best
friend back in high school up until he
slept with his crush after masahito
mentions that more food supplies will
arrive at noon the next day he suggests
that a serum is needed to heal kyoshi's
wounds ryota and himiko bring masahito
to shiki's house to retrieve the
medicine as the three split up masahito
finds some expired medicine and puts
them in his case which he entrusts to
riota who has a strange feeling about
this when ryotar signals himiko she
comes back running and shouts at him to
drop the case this is because masahito
discreetly placed a remote control bim
inside the case which soon detonates
after riota is seemingly killed kimiko
loses the will to fight but shiki saves
her and wounds masahita with a sickle
after masahito sets off a remote control
bim on shiki himiko laments on never
having the chance of revealing her true
identity to ryota the doctor throws one
of ryota's cracker bims at himiko but it
fails to detonate as it's revealed that
ryota has survived masahito runs from
ryota to luhim into another trap and
activates the remote control bim not
knowing that ryota had moved the remote
control bim to another location which
explodes and injures masahito ryota and
himiko hesitate to finish him off until
shiki appears eager to kill him in that
last moment she alters the path of the
blade next to him saying that she'll
never forgive him afterwards ryota and
himiko find three corpses that have
their icy chips removed as the two head
back to their place ryota realizes that
kiyoshi would be the only one who knew
about the three corpses when ryotar
begins climbing the ladder he hears a
homing beam approaching and figures out
that kyoshi has turned against them
kiyoshi hallucinating of his son and his
wife both waiting for his return targets
ryota from the forest with his homing
bim ryotar dodges the homing bim only to
be targeted by another injuring his leg
while he blames himself for kiyoshi's
ordeal supported by himiko they can
avoid more homing bims in which kyoshi
panics and flees when ryota and himiko
go after him ryotar tries to apologize
for his actions hiyoshi feeling sorry
for betraying them detonates its last
homing bim when he becomes surrounded by
the komodo dragons to atone for his sins
as ryotar mourns for him himiko takes
all the icy chips from kyoshi and they
return to their hideout there himiko
asks ryota to kill her so that he can
leave the island but he refuses riot
then finally recognizes himiko as the
person he knew from batum and kisses her
ryota stops when he senses her fear but
promises to data for real when they
return home elsewhere back on the
mainland several employees from
terraness japan leave for the island
when it said that there are mechanical
problems on the island one of the
employees silently apologizes to riota
saying that it was the best he could do
perhaps a sign that he did something to
help reorder so this is it for today's
video if you like the video give it a
huge thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel for more videos farewell till
next time